welcome to lecture 15 of 1413
today we're going to talk about utility
from beliefs overall lectures 15 and 16
are talking about
utility from beliefs and learning
while in the previous lecture we talked
about attention and sort of the idea
that attention might be
limited or wrong so we might not have
the capacity to
um attend as much as we can and then
sort of thought a little bit about like
what kinds of things are people paying
attention to and can it be that people
systematically attend to the wrong
things and miss important things in the
world
let me talk about different deviations
from perhaps
optimal belief or optimal information
acquisition
which is people might derive utility
directly from beliefs
therefore have potential incentives to
deceive themselves in certain ways
next time we're going to talk about more
about learning
instead of deviations or systematic
deviations from of asian
learning
so so just summarize today we're going
to talk about utility from beliefs
people directly deriving utility from
beliefs from what they think about the
world about themselves what's going to
happen
in the future or how
smart they are and so on on monday
we're going to talk about non-vegetable
asian learnings this is the idea that
people essentially
have trouble on being invasion learners
being invasion is quite hard you may
have taken a probability
theory and so on and kind of learned
quite a bit um
but even as a very smart and educated um
mit student there will be beijing
learning problems that are way too hard
once you have
several variables lots of information
it's just really hard to do these things
in your head and people might just not
be
very good at it and then sort of use
heuristics and biases
instead um and then after that we're
going to talk about projection and
attribution
um on bias which is essentially and
people have trouble
predicting how they might feel in
different states of the world if you're
hungry it might be hard for you to not
think
uh about being hungry uh think about
like how it might feel when you're not
hungry
if you're sad it might be very difficult
for you to understand how it feels
um when you're happy and so on
um and so i should say on on a thursday
and friday tomorrow
um you're going to talk in recitation
about bayesian learning
which is sort of like how did economists
or statisticians think like you
should optimally learn what sort of like
the bayesian benchmark here
and we're going to talk then about on
monday deviations from that
okay so the first big picture overview
is like why
might people miss information and fail
to learn what are potential reasons why
my people
do that now we talked about two
potential
issues already last time one is very
broadly attention is limited
that's to say there's so much
information in the world that you just
cannot attend to everything right and so
so one specific example
was like an attention to taxes but you
can think about like there's lots of
different prices in the world there's
just way too much
information in the world for you to
attend to everything
and so one example that we talked about
was in attention to taxes is saying
that taxes that are um not included in
the sales price
might be easily missed by people and we
have this very nice paper by chad yadal
that sort of demonstrated that that
people essentially systematically
undress or under uh appreciate taxes
that they're exposed to
taxes that are sort of uh people paying
way more attention to taxes that are
directly included in the sales price
compared to taxes that are only added at
the counter and of course
both of them you have to pay and so you
really should not really under
appreciate those
taxes because that's just uh expensive
for you we did not get much into like
why are people doing that but more like
showed existence if people seem to be
missing um those texts
then we talked about like uh uh reasons
why people
might systematically and even in the
presence of lots of data
in front of them might not update uh
properly even if there are in fact
invasions
and the reason might be that they might
have the wrong theories of the world you
might think that certain variables are
just not
important for your well-being or for any
important things in the world and
therefore you have essentially since
your attention is limited
you will only collect some information
you only attend or
focus your scarce attention and memory
to what you think is important things in
the world
and so now um uh uh if you do that
you might systematically miss um or not
collect
data that would help you sort of
essentially improve your theories
and and therefore even in the very long
run even when you get lots of data
you will not update notice that that's
quite different from
rational inattention theories rational
and attention theories would sort of say
well
people's attention is limited but they
focus attention to
whatever they find whatever is most
important for them
so it can't really be that they have
like huge losses from
uh elapses of attention because you know
if they were then they would sort of
direct their attention to something
uh that that could be potentially
important in contrast the the
learning by noticing paper the cd paper
by hana adult that we discussed
uh provides a reason why people might
not pay attention to stuff that's really
important for them
and so again like if your theory says
that
a certain aspect of certain information
is not helpful you will not pay
attention to those
pieces of information and if you don't
pay attention to those pieces of
information
you will never update your wrong
theories and the wrong theory will
essentially persist
for a long time potentially forever
we're going to talk now about two other
reasons
for potentially wrong beliefs one is
anticipatory agility this is like
essentially people
like to look forward to good things in
the world suppose you have a vacation
coming up in six weeks six months from
now you might think about this positive
event
going forward essentially good or bad
events in the future that might happen
and you might drive utility from those
events
already now second there's
what people call eagle utility which is
people derive utility from thinking that
they are
smart good looking and so on so
essentially
they derive utility from thinking
positively about themselves
now for both of those kinds of pieces of
utility
people now potentially have some
incentives to
um delude themselves
and uh to think that things are perhaps
better
than they actually are because that will
make them happier
and so then often there's at the end of
the day there's some tradeoff between
having overly positive positive or
optimistic beliefs
will make people happier um they feel
good about themselves they feel about
good things happening in the future
but you know that may come at the cost
of like not
preparing or taking wrong actions um uh
uh because people are sort of overly
optimistic right so one
example would be like people might not
get tested for
certain diseases because they um they
want to think that they're they're
healthy people and want to be happy
about
their future and look forward to a
positive future but of course if they
were getting tested
that would help them to take optimal
actions potentially medication or any
other actions reacting
to to the potential disease that they
may have and for ego utility for example
if you always think that you're smarter
than you actually are well that might
make you happy
but at the same time that might have
come in some costs and like you might
not prepare properly for some exams or
interviews
other things you might just miss
important things that might hurt you
along the way
um and then finally um the last reason
that we might
that we'll talk about um next week is
people might simply just be bad at
beijing learning
there's no utility from beliefs or or
the like involved
it's just a lot of the computational
issues that we ask people to do
um are just really hard and people might
be bad at that
and uh therefore people um
use heuristics and biases and then
systematically that
most of the time these sources and
viruses are quite helpful and help
people making you know reasonable
decisions
but then often these first six and
biases are in some ways
systematically wrong in some cases and
we can sort of then
think about some systematic errors and
perhaps other some ways in which you can
improve people's decision makings
but by avoiding these errors
um now let's talk about utility from
beliefs
so it's important to understand that
economists typically define utility
functions over
outcomes such as money consumption
health
think of these things as like things
that people consume one way or other or
things that they can usually
measure in some ways i can look at like
you have money and then if you have
money you will spend it
on your consumption goods it could be
like apples and bananas of course that
would be also like haircuts or other
services
or health for example you you know i can
measure when you have good or bad health
usually you think about some outcomes
that could be levels of outcomes so
essentially like you know three apples
or five apples so seven apples are the
arguments of utility function
it could be also as we've discussed when
we talked about reference dependent
utility
it could be in part being deviations
from some reference points on changes
over time
but importantly here the arguments are
like goods and services
like essentially are the arguments of
the
utility function instead another source
of utility could be
beliefs about such outcomes so now it's
about like what might happen
either in the future or what's happening
right now
uh and you might directly um derive
utility from such
beliefs now such utility from beliefs
can be a very powerful source of utility
uh one example for example would be a
high profile public speech
suppose you have to give like a public
speech in front of the entire university
now of course you might sort of divide
utility directly from that experience
itself you might like it a lot you might
find it very stressful so like the
10 20 30 whatever minutes however long
your speeches
might be
might give you positive or negative
utility but perhaps the utility
of that experience itself might be or
could be dwarfed by the stress and as a
anticipation derived beforehand from
anticipating it
um that is to say like you might think
about it you might prepare about it you
might
like worry about it you might not sleep
at night so there might be lots of like
stress or positive excitement and
anticipation
um every day if you you give a speech
like sometime in september
every day until september you know think
about it positively or negatively and
you might derive
positive or negative anticipatory
utility um
from it there's another part of utility
that we're not going to talk about is
utility from memories so you might
afterwards
look back and say oh that was really
nice and you have a video then you
really enjoy it and so on
i'm gonna not talk about that but that
sort of like backward looking utility
could be quite important
um as well now um when you think about
utility from beliefs
one way i think that this is all in your
head but it turns out that utility from
beliefs can actually even affect
physical outcomes in particular there's
a
large body of research on placebo
effects and
which is defined as a treatment that can
help patients merely because
he or she believes it well that is to
say if you give
people like a placebo like a sugar pill
something that essentially has no active
ingredient
and uh tell them that this is um
in fact an effective drug for something
that
drug itself relative to control might
have
treatment effects now um that
often is the case for um things like
uh pain medication and the lie and
usually you think you know pain
medication if you give people placebo
pills
um compared to like sort of actual pain
medication uh these drugs are like about
a third of as effective as like pain
medication depends of course
on the dosage um so that's quite
powerful but then you might say well
that's only in people's head and maybe
people just say they're happier or less
in pain when in fact they're not there's
also some studies have actually found
some physical symptoms so you give
people a placebo pill and there's
actually
physically in some measurable ways uh
hard measures not just
self-reports people are doing better so
these placebo effects can be in fact
um quite powerful so when you now think
about sort of like um
uh overall about sources of utility
it's hard to imagine in fact any source
of utility that's not influenced to some
extent by beliefs
right often it's about like how uh you
look forward to some things
it's not just about going to a
restaurant or a date or having like fun
with friends
a lot of it is also just the
anticipation
of that okay
so now more specifically what do we mean
by anticipatory utility
um so many uh emotions are in particular
are intimately linked
related to what a person thinks about
the future when you think about like
hope
fear anxiety savoring etc
a lot has to do with like some stuff
that might happen in the future some
events that
uh might happen for sure or some events
that could happen and they're just
worried about
such as when people are afraid and
anxious about certain things
those are actually things that might
happen even with a pretty low
probability
yet people right now might be um for
sure
quite anxious or worried or afraid
now um uh what is then sort of how do we
define to think about anticipatory
utility
well it's utility derived now from
anticipating in the future
so there's like stuff that in the future
enters your utility function
directly and those events that will
happen in the future
could be consumption could be also like
services could be also like bad shocks
or any things that will happen
in the future um right now in the
current period
you're already feeling good or bad about
it or something that will happen uh
uh one or several periods in the future
and sort of anticipate utility is a
prime example of utility from beliefs
now how might anticipatory utility
affect behaviors
um you can think about broadly speaking
two classes of implications that we are
going to think about
there's sort of other potential effects
that might be there so
the first one is people if they have
anticipatory utility
um that might affect the choice of
timing of certain outcomes
but that is to say if you have the
choice when you can have experience a
certain good
you might want to delay that or or not
depending on your participatory control
for example if i ask you would you like
to go on a vacation
next week or in six weeks six months
from now or six weeks from now
you might say um in fact six months from
now
is preferable because then you'll have
six months to look forward to that
experience and be really excited about
it
instead if i say it's only next week
well then it might be fun to go next
week and maybe you know if you're
discounting you'd rather have it earlier
than later
but then there's not very much time to
look forward to it
and uh to savor and sort of be excited
about this experience
so anticipatory utility might affect um
the choice of timing of outcomes we're
gonna talk about this
in a bit second and perhaps more
consequentially anticipatory utility
also may affect
people's beliefs and their information
acquisition
that is to say if there are some things
that i like to look forward to in life
for example if i think you know i'm a
healthy person i'm going to age really
happily and
want to live until age 90 i'm happily
for a long time well then for example
um that anticipatory utility might
depend a lot on like
the beliefs about my health styles and
now if they were like
tests or some information that i could
um acquire
be it like about like um hiv
be it about like cancer be it about
huntington's disease alike
it's a very serious potential diseases
people um might under use or under
acquire such type of information because
they want to maintain
overly positive beliefs about what's
going to happen in the future
and that could be potentially quite
important because if people are
not getting for example cancer screening
well then
some treatments that perhaps could be
done very early might be delayed
and that could be potentially quite
costly we're going to talk about this
second okay let me show you some
motivating evidence of anticipatory
utility
this is not so much to examine establish
the existence of such utility you're
sort of like a very rigorous test and
showing like exactly this is
anticipating to it and how much of that
is there
but rather to get you to start thinking
about the patterns of behavior um
generated by it so george lawrence team
uh
ingeniously asked undergrads about their
hypothetical
willingness to pay now to obtain or
avoid certain
experiences so they ask them what their
willingness to pay as a function of the
amount of time
until the experience occurs so all
values are normalized relative to
student's willingness to pay to obtain
the experience
right away so you ask people about like
with you how much are you going to pay
for right away and uh 24 hours from now
and three days from now and a year from
now five years ten years from now
and then uh the willingness to pay right
now
is uh is one by definition and
everything is relative to that
what are the experiences that he asked
people about
um there's a sort of both pleasant and
unpleasant experiences
um uh one of them is receiving monetary
gain or avoiding monetary losses
there's obtaining a kiss for a movie
star of the student's choice
and there's avoiding a non-lethal but
very painful electric shock and now that
sort of you can think about like why
lowenstein asked about like hypothetical
willingness to pay because you know
implementing that
uh would be pretty tough to actually do
now um when you think about these types
of um experiences you can think a bit
about like
what would your hypothetical willingness
to baby and how would that look like uh
as a function
of of the timing would it go up or would
it go down over time
um and there's going to be like two
forces that play there's going to be
discounting at play and there's going to
be anticipatory utility
at play we talked about discounting
already a lot which is like people like
to have
positive stuff in the present or rather
in the present then in the future
uh people like to like push negative
stuff away to the future so if bad stuff
is going to happen
like an electric shock you'd rather have
that like 10 years from now
rather than like right away so then
the question now is how does
anticipatory utility uh
affect those kinds of choices
and um um already gave you some of this
intuition um to start with which is like
if you had a vacation that you were
can experience would you rather have
this like right now would you ever
either
have it in like a week from now or six
months from now or like 10 years from
now
well it depends on your anticipatory
utility you might prefer to have it in
six months from now because that allows
you to look forward to it for quite a
long time
you might not want to have it like 10
years from now that might be good from a
perspective of anticipatory utility but
it's really really far away and you'd
rather have things
in the present than in the future um so
maybe unless you take together like
anticipatory utility
and discounting um you'd rather uh
have it in an immediate amount of time
from now which gives you the sort of a
form of like an inverse
u shape of valuations over time
or evaluations as a function of when the
right now of a function of what's going
to happen
in the future let me show you what i
mean um so when you look at
um low and students examples
in particular the kiss is um of the
movie star
is uh an example of like an inverse you
where like it's a pleasant experience
and what seems to be the case is that so
people prefer
um that experience to happen in
in three hours 24 hours three days
and one year from now compared to uh
immediately
you see the values here are always um
higher than one which is sort of what
things are normalized to
uh so let me back up for a second what
does this graph show it shows the time
delay on the x-axis which is like
immediately three hours 24 hours three
days one year
ten years from now on the x-axis that's
when the
actual experience is happening and on
the y-axis is the proportion
of the current value again it's
normalized to one so the evaluation
immediately
is one notice that these are
willingness to to pay to receive the
experience
or willingness to pay to avoid it so
everything is positive
now for the kiss now we see that the
delay of three days from now seems to
have the highest valuation so that
people like um to latest forbid
um notice that like discounting would
not generate you this pattern
discounting would say you kind of want
to right away
um because you really enjoy this
experience um so anticipatory will
you tell you would say well three days
from now and even a year from now it's
better
um because you know now you can save or
really look forward to be excited about
it um when that's happening
however you know ten years from now
people seem to like less than right now
presumably because it's really really
far away so a i guess you're discounting
not a lot and sort of the experience
itself gets discounted a lot
b you might even like um the
anticipatory utility might only kick in
like nine years from now because it's
really so far away
that like you know it's hard to think
about this even like because it's so far
away
and you might even discount you might
experience
um participatory utility nine years from
now
but you might discount that as well
because it's really far away in the
future so it seems like people have sort
of some preference
um for the present there is some
discounting going on uh and there's sort
of two forces at play
discounting versus anticipatory
now in contrast when you look at the
shock the negative um
a shock here it seems to be that people
are um really seem to dislike
having that talk in 10 years or one year
or
from now compared to having it right
away
what's going on here well if you have
the shock like in one year 10 years from
now this is really an
unpleasant thing that hangs over your
head so what instead people want is
they'd rather sort of
have it uh uh you know get it over with
right away
and not have sort of to think about it
um uh too much um
overall now
uh that's that's again sort of the
the opposite of of of of of discounting
uh if you just had discounting what you
would say is well rather
um i'm willing to to to pay to avoid it
if it's right away it's really
unpleasant right away
it's not so bad if it's ten years from
now so what discounting would say
is uh uh you know the function should be
going down as you see it for
losing four dollars and why is that well
losing four dollars seems to be like you
know people rather
do that in the future rather than in the
present and it's not really a thing that
you think about it you don't have like a
lot of anticipatory utility about losing
four dollars in ten years so now
you know that that's not such a hugely
important thing um
however if you get like an electric
shocks and ten years ago that might be
really unpleasant
um so you really don't want to have that
in the year 10 years from now
having this hang over your head for a
long time so you'd rather have it right
away
to not have to suffer from any
anticipatory utility
even though from a discounting
perspective that's actually sort of
worse okay
and so um i already said all of this
subjects prefer
a kiss from a movie star in three days
rather than now they also prefer to have
a shock now
rather than in one year or uh 10 years
remember this is willingness to pay to
avoid the situation so like
the willingness to pay right now for the
shock right now
is lower than the willingness to pay in
one or ten years so the curve is going
up
now this contradicts discounting of any
kind if you think about any discounting
like
positive or negative discounting isn't
like you might have a
preference for the president or
preference for the future you
cannot generate these kinds of patterns
in particular a pattern that's really
hard to to generate it's a pattern where
you get sort of these hump shape cases
where essentially um
for inverse use because either you want
something in the present or really far
away in the future
and uh but as i said before if you had
discounting what you would get is
essentially
things are either increasing or
decreasing and the time horizon
positive things you want right away
negative things
you'd rather have in the future and this
is not at all what lowenstein
finds now what is a natural explanation
people look forward to the kiss and
delay to enjoy anticipation
and it's very unpleasant to anticipate
the shock so they get it over with
quickly now why did lowenstein choose
the kiss example
you think about this for a second
well it is an experience with high
degree of favorability something you can
think about and look forward to in the
future
um lawrencium tries to rule out
alternative explanations based on
preparation you might sort of say well
um
kissing a movie star right away might
not be great because you know you want
to like
get ready uh uh you know shower um
um sleep well and tell all your friends
about it and so on and sort of days sort
of like um
uh or like get some advice on which
movie star to pick up
on so there might be some reason that
preparation might push you in three days
from now
um similarly if you had sort of sat at
dinner at a french restaurant instead
you might say well
um in a few days this delay is perfectly
reasonable even without
superior utility you know you might sort
of like want to make
a time right and why it might not be a
good time you want to get a date etc for
the dinner so like
choosing stuff later um because of
preparation seems really reasonable
that's not what
lowenstein is talking about here um he
really is thinking about sort of like
anticipatory utility and um
so here's some other examples where like
really you can sort of
argue that really this is not about
preparation
but um you know part of that could be
preparation as well but what you really
think about is going on is really this
is about anticipatory utility
when you think about like is preparation
problematic for the electric
shock in particular well the answer is
no because that would induce
um subjects who prefer it later which is
not what lowenstein finds
remember bowenstein finds that people
would like to have the shock
right away as opposed to like a year or
10 years from now
and so preparation would say well i want
it in like three days and a year from
now
instead but that's not really what what
um
lewinsky fines so maybe if you're not
happy with the preparation explanation
for the uh case of the movie star
preparations will not be able to
to explain to you the electric shock
example
okay uh there's another example so
lauren sort of has this funny thing
where he says well
um uh uh getting elected shock is kind
of a little bit of a weird example
so let me find something more realistic
and then being an academic
uh what he comes up with is cleaning
hamster cages
so he asked subjects how much uh
they'd have to be paid to clean a
hundred hamster cages
i've never cleaned any hamster cages in
my life i imagine it'd be quite
unpleasant
so you think about what kinds of
patterns do you expect
to see and what do you expect to see is
sort of something similar to the
electric shock
so people might really not look forward
to cleaning hamster
cages in like a while from now and
rather should do it right away
to avoid anticipatory utility that would
be the pattern that people
um uh so like the willingness to pay for
uh avoiding right away um
or you'd have to pay them like not so
much to do it right away compared to
having to do it like in a while from now
because the anticipatory utility makes
things worse as it did for the electric
shock
and this is what um uh lowenstein finds
if the payment is now for cleaning to be
performed next week it's going to be
like
30 uh but if the payment is now from
cleaning to be performed in
a year from now the payment has to be
higher it's
37 and again this sounding of
preparation of the light would sort of
create you the opposite um people would
rather have it in the future than in the
present which is not um what loyalty
finds
notice again these are willingness uh uh
to pay
to avoid um or to try to to to have to
do the experience so how much would you
would i have to pay you to do it
now again there's sort of two forces
here at play
there is uh discounting versus
anticipation um
now how do we think about discounting so
we talked about discounting before and
sort of there uh
sort of three steps from thinking about
discounting or that we talked about
one was there was a question kind of
like what determines a person's
instantaneous utility etched each point
in time
we didn't talk about this very much
during time preference we were just
saying like here's an instantaneous
utility function that determines like
how happy you are at each point in time
what we talked a lot about was like then
how do people integrate or aggregate
those utilities
across time so we have some utility
today tomorrow two days three days from
now
and we then talked about like how do you
aggregate how much weight do you put on
the different
periods and then we talked about like
what does a person predict about the
future utility and behavior
which is sort of the questions about
sophistication and naivete
that we discussed as well so as i said
you know the discounting issues you
covered are
about point number two the
sophistication versus naivete issues
are about points number three and here
people's prediction about their future
utility and behavior was only relevant
to the extent that it was helpful or
harmful
in making people helping people make
good decisions right so we didn't care
people didn't
derive utility from being uh
sophisticated or naive
um uh directly um uh people only derived
utility from their instantaneous utility
function and from like the
or depending on the weight they put on
those uh different instantaneous
utilities
um but their prediction affected kind of
like their choices
and their choices in turn affected the
utilities but it was never the case that
people's
predictions their beliefs directly enter
the utility function
so instead anticipatory utility is about
point number one
it's about like the instantaneous
utility function what goes into that
um and perhaps people's beliefs about
the future
might do that that's what what we're
going to talk about we're talking about
now
now notice that sort of thing like
social preferences or
reference dependent preferences those
were also about item number one
again time preferences so far that we
talked about more about items number two
and three now what are sort of the
interactions between anticipation and
discounting
uh we talked about this already so you
can sort of distinguish between
pleasant and unpleasant experiences so
um uh uh so a anticipatory utility is
stronger for events that are closer in
time right something that's like 10
years from now you're not that worried
about
um right now uh uh for something that's
like tomorrow
or in two hours from now you might be
really worried about
now for pleasant unsavorable experiences
some delay is optimal to have a few
periods of anticipation so think about
like each hour each day is a period of
anticipation
so you'd rather have like three days and
two days than one day of participation
because you know
each day it counts as a day of
participation and you may value each day
but you don't want it to be too far away
because then there's also like
discounting you'd rather have things
in the present or like close to the
present than in the future
you don't want stuff to be like in a
year or two years from now because
that's really far away
and then you discount that experience
very much notice that you might also
discount the anticipatory utility
that is to say you might sort of suppose
you have only three days of
anticipatory utility of like a nice
restaurant or some nice experience
only the three days before that
experience
you're gonna be um uh excited about it
well then if that's in ten years from
now you're gonna discount
all of that and sort of then that's
really far away and if you really sort
of present bias or just discount a lot
then um uh uh you only got also going to
discount the anticipatory utility
so there's some trade-off for savorable
pleasant experiences between
uh discounting anticipatory utility
which might give you this
inverse u um pump shape pattern
instead or in contrast for unpleasant uh
fearful experiences
you might either do it immediately to
eliminate periods of anticipation so you
might just say get it out of the way i
don't want any anticipatory to
utility and getting it out of the way
essentially minimizes anticipatory
utility because you
get it over with um or
you might put it off as much as possible
for discounting reason and to weaken
anticipation that's to say let's just do
it in 10 years from now
i might not worry about it for quite a
while i might also just
discount any future anticipation and you
know
for discounting if there's stuff in the
future i'd rather have like bad stuff
happen in the future than in a present
because essentially discount uh the
future and it's good for me to discount
bad stuff
that's happening in the future
so far we talked about the implications
of anticipatory utility for the timing
of consumption
right that is to say when would you like
a certain
experience to to happen uh and the
immediate
uh present uh in a few days or
further away in the future but we sort
of took it as given that something might
happen
um and the question was just um when you
can think of like some examples
where that might be important um perhaps
more important overall
for people's um welfare decisions and
perhaps also for policy
is people's information gathering and
beliefs
that is to say you know you might get
situations where like anticipatory or
eager utility isn't going to show you
might affect how much uh information
people gather
um and they might not be as informed as
they could be otherwise
because of those anticipatory utility
reasons
so one question you might sort of ask
yourself is well would an individual
in a non-strategic setting with no
anticipatory utility ever
strictly prefer to refuse free
information
and it's actually hard to come up with
some situations where people just would
confuse information if they're sort of
perfectly near classical
you might sort of say well people might
be overwhelmed there's like too much
information available and you might not
be able to
attend to everything but in general i
think the assumption in economics is
well well the information could be
useful
for something like you know you might
not even know that right now but it
might turn out that actually it's quite
interesting information and in
particular usually the assumption is
there's like free disposal
right if the information is not useful
just forget about it don't care about it
whatever just write it down somewhere
and like
whatever it might be important in the
future but really why bother uh
while not to have it it's no problem so
you never like
refuse it or um directly um
you might not like pay for it if you
think it's useless but you would never
refuse to
to to actually um get it for free
in contrast somebody with anticipatory
feeling
cannot ignore information because that
information affects
his or her emotions right if something
that some piece of information makes you
really unhappy
well it's very hard to actually forget
about it and sort of ignore it
because once it's out there once you've
heard it it's really that you can't
unhear it
and it's very hard to forget in
particular it's hard to forget stuff
that you really care about
uh that you will upset about or anxious
about and so on that's really hard
to do and so uh
one uh quite interesting example is uh
dr house
and 13. uh 13 was um is one of his
employees um she was called 13 because
she i think he had like 25 or something
um
interns and i think he fired almost all
of them except for uh 13 he was number
13 of these interns
he never at the beginning at least
bothered to learn people's names so he
just gave them numbers so 13 with number
13
she was an excellent doctor it turns out
that her
family had history of hunting's hunting
this disease
and 13 had the um how to do the prime
example
of in the show of information avoidance
she did not want to
learn about uh whether she had the
disease or not and so
huntington's disease is such that if
your parents
have the disease your probability of
having disease yourself is way higher
than in the general population it's
about 50 percent
overall if one of your parents have the
disease
um and so then you might sort of think
it's quite valuable to learn about
whether you have
disease or not for a variety of
decisions that you might make in the
future
or that are relevant for the future
ranging from like when to retire
how much to exercise what education to
get how much to save whether you have
children or not
um and uh house dr house who's usually
you know pretty irrational and various
um
uh choices or decisions that he does uh
was in fact
um being uh sort of very narrow
classical here instead of saying like
you should get this information because
it would be very helpful for you
in fact to look like behind her back
tested her and created
and sent her the results and but then a
13
for at least for quite a while did not
go to look at these results
presumably because she wanted to make
herself uh think that she'll be
healthy and sort of delude herself in
some ways about like
being a healthy person and not having
this disease even though she was not
sure and so once uh so
avoiding that information helps you do
that because once you're tested you're
either positive or negative
and it's very hard to that and ignore
that information uh once you've seen it
but before you have been tested you can
always sort of delude yourself and make
yourself think that
you don't have the disease now
what is hunting this disease going to be
a little bit more specific
it's a degenerative neurological
disorder it's a very um
severe and heartbreaking disease
essentially it sort of
impacts the brain uh it sets on around
hh
40 and sort of like really makes people
very
dysfunctional and life expectancy is
around 60 for somebody with huntington's
disease
compared to like you know 80 or even
higher for people who don't have
huntington's disease
um people with parents or a parent with
hunting disease have about a 50
chance of developing hunting disease
themselves
um since the 1990s there's a genetic
blood test available
and so you can provide at-risk
individuals with certainty about whether
they develop will develop it
so you don't know for sure either you
will develop it or you will not
and those lab tests cost about 200 to
300
um plus you know consulting and other
costs
uh the tests here are often covered by
insurance but most
uh tests are paid out of pockets emily
oster
co-authors the paper that
is on the reading list were arguing that
people were not doing that partially to
keep the tests
test results private um importantly
there's no
cure or nothing that you can actually do
to
improve the disease so when you think
about other diseases such as like hiv or
other like
usually there there's a key motivation
to learn about whether somebody is
positive or negative
um because then they can get an er enter
anti-retroviral treatment of the like
here um that's not the case so there's
no actual cure
or behaviors that you could do so that
could sort of mitigate
the course of the disease however
there's sort of other potential
behaviors that you could engage in
to sort of like prepare you better and
deal better with the disease once it
sets on
so here's what are these reasons why why
could such a test prevail value we'll
think about this for a second
there's a number of um potential reasons
that you might think about
i've listed like a few there's a
question about whether or not might you
want to have a child
there's issues about like marriage uh uh
would you like to
get married or find a partner do you
want to tell your partner and so on
there's questions about retirement when
you want to
do you want to retire for example if you
wanted to travel a lot after retirement
well um if the disease sets on at age 40
you might want to sort of do that a lot
earlier education usually we think that
the returns to education
are high so it's a good news for anybody
who's studying
but usually these returns are accrued
over a long period of time right you're
done with the education at the age like
22 or 25
you can then sort of uh start working
from age 25 to age
um 65 or the likely even longer and
so that's a long time but if instead
you're a patterns disease you might only
have until age 40 or 45 but the like
so the returns to education are way
lower
you might also sort of do things like
participation in clinical research
perhaps there's like some
chance that at some point there might be
a cure you might be want to contribute
to that it's on so there's lots of
potential benefits of knowing and that
test could really be extremely valuable
um for you and surely uh the value could
be higher than 200 300
um now what is the paper by oscar daldu
so australia observed a sample of
previously untested
at-risk individuals over the course of
10 years
um why is it useful to have like a
a sample of at-risk individuals
well because the base rate the rate of
people who
are not at risk who don't have any
parents um uh with huntington's disease
that um rate is quite low so not being
tested is not so much a puzzle if your
chances like you know 0.00 something
percent
then it's really not that uh it's quite
costly to do it's 200 300
plus you know hassle costs and so on and
you know there's many diseases one could
have
y tests for hunting since it's perfectly
reasonable to not test for it
but here there are people these at risk
people uh
um their chance is like um
uh uh 50 to start with so there's a lot
to learn from you go from 50
to either zero percent of having it or
100 of having it
so there's huge um changes in your
beliefs potentially
while if you are a non-uh a person who's
not at risk
your ra your chance of getting it to
start with is like point zero zero
something percent
with very high chance you're going to go
to zero from that so that's
almost no change at all anyway there's
only like a tiny tiny chance that you're
actually positive
in which of course you might want to
change your behavior quite a bit
but the weight on that should be quite
low because the probability of a low
test at positive tests is really well
so um oster and i'll find um
very low rates of this genetic testing
fewer than 10
of individuals pursue predictive testing
during the studies over this long period
of time
many individuals get tested to confirm
the disease rather than sort of actually
learning about
whether they have it or not you might
think you know what's really important
is for the reasons that i mentioned here
is generating knowledge right you want
to know um
should you um retire early or not
for that you kind of want knowledge you
want to sort of reveal uncertainty
so if your chance to have the disease
starting with fifty percent
going from fifty percent to zero percent
or fifty two hundred percent
that's like huge uh uh potential
knowledge that's being created
um once you think you know the chance is
like 99 or 99.9
going from ninety nine percent a hundred
percent you actually don't learn that
much and you shouldn't change your
behavior very much
from like confirming that you have the
disease um
similarly actually the similar evidence
in studies on hiv breast cancer and
other types of testing
people tend to systematically under test
even if the chance of like having
certain diseases is quite high
now what's somewhat different for hiv
and cancer any cancer
nuclear breast cancer testing there's at
least
some hope that if a disease gets the
test and detected early
one can potentially do something about
it there's some recent um
controversies or or discussions unlike
is the cancer testing actually helpful
and i'll be over testing in the sense is
the test actually helpful and uh
into detecting of potential diseases but
truly for hiv it would be quite valuable
if you if you knew early on whether you
have disease or not because then you can
essentially
uh take erb antiretroviral treatment
to help you now
let me show you first like who's getting
tested so what you see on this graph
is on the x-axis investigator evaluation
of symptoms
at the last um visit so on the uh
on the left these are people who are
normal who don't show any symptoms on
the right people have like certain signs
of heart disease and
everything else in between is sort of in
the middle of that
so like further to the right uh means
like people have like more
uh symptoms in particular to the very
right people these are people who have
like certain symptoms of hepatitis
disease
and what we see is on the y-axis where
the people since um their last visit get
um tested so there's several visits over
time
and um the the the raw means
are uh which i wanted you to focus on
this is sort of the upper of those
two lines and what we see essentially
that testing rates are like
very very low uh the largest about like
five percent
in this particular sample and that's
essentially
increasing um in the uh symptoms that
people have
so overall that fraction is is high and
in particular for people where you think
you know the value of testing would be
quite high
these are test people who don't
necessarily show any symptoms
and people who have like some symptoms
but not like very strong symptoms you
would think you know for them
it'd be particularly helpful to get
tested
because you can learn a lot um but
instead you know those are in fact the
people who
almost test at all that has traits are
something like one two three percent
now uh uh as i said before for
people with certain signs of hunting
disease the objective knowledge from the
test is very long since there's no cure
you kind of know almost like uh you're
almost true that you have it anyway
so in a way like you just really don't
learn very much if you have these
certain signs of having disease plus
you're sort of genetically
predisposed to have the disease the
chance of like actually having diseases
like almost one anyway
so test really does not give you a lot
of information however perhaps
it sort of changes your utilities from
beliefs which i'm going to talk about
in a bit notice that the perceived
probabilities of having disease might be
lowering for people with certain
symptoms
so what i'm showing you here is the
investigator evaluation this is like
essentially like a doctor a neurologist
a leg
is actually looking at the symptoms and
looking at you know objectively what's
your chance of having disease
that's different from what people
actually uh think they have
so i guess a and what we learned here is
like the testing rates are quite low
um second people systematically
uh underpredict or are over optimistic
about
not having the disease that is what i'm
showing you here is like a motor score
which essentially is like
an assessment of like how good are your
motor skills and one unfortunate thing
about huntington's disease is that your
motor skills
are deteriorating a lot and sort of a
high score he
means here essentially um
is bad means essentially you're not
doing well and you're more likely to
have huntington's disease
and what you see in the upper on the
y-axis you see essentially the
probability
the objective and subjective
probabilities of having the disease
the upper line here that you see at the
top that line
is the actual probability sort of the
estimated actual probability
and you see that's essentially
increasing uh in in the motor scores
so people who have like almost no
symptoms uh
overall they have essentially like a 50
chance of having the disease um that's
sort of the risk to start with
but then once people have more symptoms
that chance sort of increases and once
you have a motor score of like in the
20s or 30s
your objective probability of having
disease is close to a
one now in contrast the second line that
you see here in the middle
that is the people's perceived
probabilities
those perceived probabilities are vastly
lower and
and far less steep than the actual
probabilities
you see that people's perceived
probabilities at when they have like no
symptoms
are still actually reasonably high and
they're pretty close to the truth
they're about 40 compared to like
something like 50 55
um so that's actually not that far off
perhaps because it's very clear if you
have a parent who
has a disease everybody knows
essentially in particular in this kind
of study
everybody knows that the probability of
having the disease is high and sort of
that
perhaps people can't really lie to
themselves they know that the chance is
pretty high
if they have been untested but then
people seem to be largely in denial when
it comes to these symptoms
people seeing you know people have these
symptoms and when you have life scores
of 20 to 30
um their perceived probability of having
a disease is really only slightly higher
it's about 50 percent or the like these
are the people who are about here
while their actual probability is much
higher so people don't seem to like
update information
that's really unfavorable towards to
them in terms of like
uh anticipatory utility but because they
seem to be feeling
bad about it notice that there's
actually a significant share of people
who um persists and really thinks about
um or reports uh
saying that there's no chance of having
the disease so there are some people
have like a motor uh
uh score of like 20 to 30 and they uh
you know 10 and 20 of people here seem
to say i have a zero chance of having
disease which really seems to sort of be
uh unfortunately um delusional in some
ways but really these might be people
who really just
do not want to to think about it and are
just really worried and anxious and
they'd rather sort of like
rule out that probability of being sick
for themselves
now one important question then is what
do individuals
adjust their behaviors right so so far
we talked about like
are people getting tested uh and the
answer is large
no second are people what are people's
beliefs
about the disease and people seem to
essentially be overly optimistic
now there's a question well does that
translate into their
behaviors and now um this is another
sort of
a little bit complicated graph but
essentially what the figures
uh uh shows uh figure shows is
coefficients
relative to those tested negative for
huntington's disease let's focus on the
black graphs to start with
these are people who are certain to have
the disease compared to
people who are tested negative so what
we're comparing here is people are
tested positive
compared to people who tested negative
and so the coefficients if they're
positive essentially means that people
are more likely to get the worse
more likely to retire more likely to
change their finances recently or their
efficacy preparation they're also more
likely to be
um pregnant so they change essentially
their behavior relative to
to um being negative so it's essentially
just comparing positive and negative
people i should have said already this
is sort of a type of um
setting where experiments are pretty
difficult and ethically difficult to do
because you know if people really derive
utility from
information providing people with
information could really make them
worse it's quite different from
other sort of experiments involving
information
people like wrong beliefs or sort of
biased information
about certain outcomes usually there you
know you would say well let's provide
them with good information maybe they
improve their
behavior so there if you provide people
with correct information you can only
make people better off
here however since people derive utility
from this information
telling them the truth about stuff that
they perhaps didn't know about
could really make them more soft and
deeply unhappy and someone wants to be
very careful
with that and therefore they're not
quite not a lot of experiments
in this space at least for now um uh
uh so the study here that i'm showing
you is essentially observational data
uh and in this case comparing people who
have adjusted positive
comparing people to a tested um negative
if you look at people who are just
tested recently
arguably these two types of people are
not that different
because you know they didn't when when
they made the choice of being tested
they didn't of course know whether they
were positive or negative
so that comparison really shows that
people do adjust their behavior so
people who have been tested positive
are more likely to change their lives in
pretty dramatic ways for example people
are more likely to get divorced more
likely retired and so on
people are also more likely to be have a
pregnancy i think this is
might be for women only or for couples
with uh uh
you know their spouse and um that seems
like a
an interesting result in a sense that's
not what i would have expected
now um uh you know that that could be in
part so
the authors in the paper itself say um
that the
the sample uh that's used to to look at
pregnancies is relatively
small so maybe in some sense one needs
to be a little cautious
interpreting those results it could be
that people
try to get pregnant or have a child when
they know about the disease
because they want to have a child early
on there seem to be some
technologies where people can in fact
avoid that their child have the disease
so you can sort of um
make sure that doesn't happen and there
might be some couples who might say well
um even if it's the case that the uh
one of the the parents um will die early
on if the person is like 20
years old alike they might sort of want
to have the child early
so they can uh spend sufficiently much
time with their child
um before the the onset of the disease
but anyway it seems to be that the
people the black lines or sort of like
relatively clearly above zero these are
coefficients
that compare essentially the black
versus the uh
the the group that's negative which is
to the positive versus negative
tested people now when you look at the
uncertain people
these are people who essentially with
some probability a positive and with
some
probability are negative what we would
sort of expect is that those people are
somewhere in between
the positive and the negative people so
you would expect that the gray lines are
also positive
perhaps not as big as the black lines
instead you see essentially except for
the pregnancy result and that doesn't
seem to be significant
perhaps because the sample is small
the gray lines are essentially close to
pretty close to zero it's essentially
people who are uncertain about the
disease behave
very similarly to people who are
tested negative so essentially people
who have not been tested were uncertain
about the disease
they behave as if they were um tested
negatively
um and perhaps or likely because they
essentially delude themselves in some
ways and sort of like
um thinking they are
a negative when there's no action that
they need to take so that really shows
or
the argument authors argue that that
shows that essentially the
lack of testing really uh changes
people's behavior
notice that it's very hard for us to
think about like welfare or people
better or worse off because of that
because of course that's a choice to do
so
and you might sort of say well i'm
really valuing thinking about i'm pretty
healthy and think life is going to be
good and that's really valuable to
people
and they take into account that like you
know changes in their finances and so on
would be valuable but they're not doing
this
because if they were doing it they would
have to acknowledge to themselves
that they are potentially at least
sick um
okay so how should we think about these
beliefs and behaviors let me sort of
summarize what we have seen
so many people don't get tested despite
arguably good reasons to do so
people are often over optimistic about
the probability of not having the
disease to spike often fairly clear
signs that they have it and that's
really seems to be very much consistent
with anticipatory uh utility people want
to feel good about themselves and about
the future
and therefore they're not getting tested
and therefore are they're overly
optimistic
such over optimism then translates into
behavior so people react
less to the signs of likely having the
disease then they arguably should
in particular people who are not tested
they look a lot in their behavior
uh similar to people who have been
tested negative
and that's to say like perhaps if they
were tested
tested positively they would change
their behavior
in ways that would be useful for them at
least along the road
now what models can explain such
behaviors it's important to understand
like neoclassical models would not
generate these facts because you would
say well you should be tested because
that could be useful
and utility is just not uh there's
essentially no utility from beliefs
so why would you not get tested you
might say well it's kind of expensive
but arguably
the value of doing so should be quite
high and part
uh uh the insurance would also even pay
for it if you were
not able to afford it now um
let me sort of write down or show you a
simple model there will be a problem
with questions uh a question on this
model um for you to sort of understand a
little better
so the model is extremely simple it has
two periods and the relevant outcomes
occur in period
two in period two the decision maker
will either be
uh negative uh with probability p so
that positive
person essentially would be healthy with
probability p and not have the disease
and it will be part that person will be
positive for its probability
one minus p the instantaneous utilities
of like in period two or how they will
feel think about period twos being like
everything in the future so period one
is the period when you think about
potentially getting tested which is like
right now or this month
or the like and period two now is like
say next year everything's starting from
uh all of the future now the
instantaneous utility of this long
future period
are you minus and your plus your minus
is if you're negative so you minus is
like
the good case and your plus is um if
you're positive
you sort of think that your minus is
larger than your plus it's better to be
negative than positive in that
disease or in general um
in period one uh we're going to look at
now people's choices we can assume
no discounting whatsoever that's just
for simplicity we also assume for now at
least that nothing can be done
about the person's condition so a and
there's no cure
b there's also no financial or other
adjustment that the person might be able
to take
uh to sort of mitigate the onset of the
disease so now we're going to just rule
that out this is just about like
do you want to find out or not and why
or why not
now what would expected utility theory
say um uh
here what what is expected utility well
it's very simple it's essentially just
like there's no anticipatory utility
expected utility is just what's going to
happen in the future
with probability p you get u minus which
is like your
your the person is negative with
probability one minus p
um the person is positive and then
receives
utility you plus notice again there's no
discounting this is in period two but
then says no discounting delta or beta
are
essentially just one okay now let's add
anticipatory utility uh to this model
notice that um it can does
this uh type of utility can only depend
on the person's beliefs about whether
she will have
the disease or not not on what actually
happens
right so the the anticipated utility
depends on the probability of having the
disease
um uh and not on the actual consequences
of the
feeds and since the person in period one
has this anticipatory utility
doesn't know for sure whether she is
going to have it or not
the anticipatory utility will only
depend on the beliefs on the probability
p
of for perceived probability p of having
the disease
now they're going to make two extreme
assumptions
about the formation of beliefs number
one is beliefs are
correct in the sense that like the
decision maker will always optimally
update their beliefs and once you've
given the decision maker like
a test the person cannot sort of just
make up their beliefs in certain ways
uh uh if the test is positive the person
knows they're positive it's negative
um a person knows that they're negative
so p is either one or zero wants to have
the test
or p is correct in the sense that like a
person
knows that it's p and there's no sort of
wrong information or beliefs about it
second the decision maker can choose to
manipulate her beliefs
you're gonna start with one which is
essentially the assumption that beliefs
are correct
let the anticipatory utility in period
one be f
of p and recall that p is the
probability of being
negative now let's assume that which is
kind of obvious in some ways
uncontroversial that u minus is larger
than u plus so essentially again
remember
uh u minus is the probability of being
negative so utility is
higher in the second period if you're
negative and when you're positive
and then f of p or f is increasing and p
that's actually not so obvious in a
sense it's not obvious that like
um going from like a certain percentage
to a higher one uh
the anticipated daily always increases
it's like a reasonable assumption but
one might be arguing
about it but for now we're gonna just
assume that f p is increasing in
p okay now does the person want to know
her uh
status well let's think about this so
um if she doesn't find out her status
her utility is
uh f of p which is the uh you know her
her probability or
without finding anything else is is p so
f of p is just your anticipatory utility
plus the term that we have before which
is just a sort of expected utility in
the future and period two which is
p times u or minus plus one minus
p times u plus now if you find out her
status she might find out that she's
either
negative or positive um if she's
negative that's with
probability p uh her utility is the
anticipatory part if she's negative she
just gets
f of one she knows for sure that she's
negative so that she is f
one plus um u minus in the second period
all of that again is with probability p
if she's positive
per utility uh is f of zero so
probability of b negative is zero plus
uh and then in the second period u of
u plus again that is with probability
one minus p
so now her expected utility is putting
these things together
is uh part here in the back which is p
times u minus plus one minus p uh
times u plus that's what we already had
above that's just the expected utility
of period two
um and you know p times uh
a negative test which is uh at
one plus 1 minus p a positive test which
is
at 4 0. okay and so now
um if you want to figure out like does
you want to get tested we just have to
compare
1 versus 2 or
2 minus one if you want if that's the
value of getting tested
notice that the expected utility part
what's going to happen in the future
will always be the same right we have p
u minus plus one minus p
u plus uh we have that here as well
the reason for that is because we cannot
be assumed uh
previously that we cannot change the
outcome
right so that's gonna cancel out if we
um subtract two minus one
um so what we're going to be left with
is like essentially
an expression that depends on f of p p
times f of one plus y minus p f of
zero when does she reject or seek
information
well she's information diverse if p of
uh p times f of 1 plus 1 minus p
times f of 0 is smaller than f of p
that's exactly and if you thought that's
the case it's exactly like a concavity
condition if f
is concave that's in fact the definition
of concavity
so if f is steeper for lower values
then the person will be information
diverse
so if the person really dislikes any
suspicion of bad news
for example due to anxiety there's not
much value added
of certainty then the person will not
get tested and not seek
information in contrast
that function is is convex
uh that is to say if it's steeper for
higher value
then the person really likes certainty
so some suspicion of bad news is not so
painful that is to say so essentially
when you think about like so if p
is starting with something like 50 what
you want to compare is like going from
50
to 100 versus from 50 to zero
and you know if going from 50 to 100 is
more valuable it's sort of like
improves your anticipatory it will do
more than going from 50
to zero percent is sort of damaging
um of p of b negative
for confusing um in the notation then
essentially the person will seek
information
and it's the opposite if the person
really dislikes any suspicion of
bad news and there's no much
added value of certain now
that is essentially just a question of
like what does this f function look like
and one could have tried to figure out
or try to estimate that function
notice that it's a very simple example
here
where essentially um the person has to
always
that there's no self-delusion or
self-deception of a like the person
always had to like
adhere to the truth
now consider now instead the possibility
that the person can manipulate their
beliefs to make yourself feel better
now one question you might ask yourself
is well in the about framework
would you want to hold correct beliefs
is there any good reason to hold correct
beliefs
and the answer is clearly no well
there's no
instrumental reason of beliefs there's
nothing you can there's no cure
you can't really make anything better
you can't really adjust your behavior
by assumption um currently so why would
you
would you ever think that you have to
disease if you can make yourself
feel better by increasing your p
so if she could believe that she's hd
negative for sure she would get higher
utility if whatever happens
later which is f of one is uh
larger than f of zero or f of one is
larger than any f
right essentially f of p is maximized we
assume that it's increasing it's
maximized at p equals one
so um uh really in the model that i
showed you before if you could choose
you really if there's really no reason
whatsoever of
uh not choosing f of one now when
there's a question well
why might you not want to choose f1
anyway
and of course the answer is well that's
because there might be instrumental
reasons there might be actually some
action that you might be able to take
to adjust your beliefs so in particular
incorrect beliefs can lead to mistaken
decisions you can essentially make worse
decisions if you have incorrect beliefs
so um uh so then there's a trade-off
right there's a trade-off between
well on the one hand if you have
incorrect beliefs if you're overly
optimistic
you feel good about it and you're
happier than you would be otherwise
because you get to enjoy anticipatory
utility but of course that might come at
the cost of like making
uh wrong decisions so in that trade-off
in general sort of a decision making but
it's just
just a decision making with anticipatory
utility
it's like over optimism leads to higher
utility than realism that is to say if
you're fully optimizing to start with
like
some over optimism um will make you
better off because essentially you get
the value of over optimism and then you
sort of not going to distort your
behavior very much if you were
optimizing to start with
so in general you can sort of like show
that
uh uh you know slight optimism and
in many cases in fact an optimal thing
to do even if it comes at
some cost and of course the intuition
here is that the person wants to believe
that she's healthy
and it makes her feel better so she
convinces her uh
herself that that's in fact the case no
now
optimal expectations essentially then as
i said you know trade off anticipatory
utility versus the value of knowledge
for
um making correct choices um
and then you know as i said you know
overly positive beliefs are an
economically important implication
of utility from beliefs so once you sort
of assume or think about
um that there might be utility from
beliefs
then you know one corollary is that
people tend to have like
overly positive beliefs because you
explain that
uh with the chili from beliefs because
really people have
incentives to be overly possible
optimistic
even if that comes at the cost of
potentially making
worse choices um next i'm going to show
you some
other evidence of overly optimistic
beliefs and then in particular we're
going to talk about
heuristics and biases uh which is again
the idea that people might be just um be
not good
agents in the sense that they might not
be good at understanding um
probabilities and how to update
probabilities accordingly
remember recitation on thursday and on
friday
is going to talk about bayesian learning
so if you wanted a refresher on that
that will be quite helpful because on
monday we're going to talk about
deviations from major learning thank you
very much
you